Oh my God.
[bleep] [bleep]
Are you alright there?
Are you okay?
Please, can you bring me
that first aid kit immediately.
[bleep]
That was terrifying.
Hell, that
was [bleep] terrifying.
Pardon my French.
Holy [bleep].
[bleep]
That was- That was a huge piece.
What? What that?
Alright.
That was a [bleep] close call.
My foot broke.
Do you feel okay?
Well, it's gone.
It fell under the- I got crushed under there.
I'm not sure that ...
[Speaking in Spanish]
[bleep]
That was as close as you can get
to getting crushed by a rock.
That was horrible.
There's only a handful
of moments in my life
where I remember time slowing down.
There are always the moments where everything can change.
I can remember six years ago, the feeling of the car
as it started to roll.
In the aftermath, I would lose my leg.
In that moment, it felt like time stopped.
And then just now,
I knew I had to get out of the way.
What a near miss, huh?
Look at that.
Look how heavy this thing is.
Look, this is half a ton of rock.
This would've killed me.
If we got within- If we got within- Like, just ...
All right, let's just get outta here.
I don't wanna think about this right now.
Everybody's pretty shooken up,
trying to make sense of what just happened.
I mean, look at this.
Carbon fiber's completely destroyed.
It was me, that boulder and then my foot on the other side,
so that means I just barely made it through.
That's too close.
I got a spare.
At least I have a spare.
Let's keep going.